[موسيقى]
يمكن أن يسبب ارتفاع درجات الحرارة قلقًا
لأصحاب
الحيوانات الأليفة، حيث لا تستطيع الحيوانات إخبارنا بما
يشعرون به، لذلك قد نحتاج إلى بعض
نصائح الخبراء. مرحبًا، أنا بن، أنا
جراح بيطري وأقوم أيضًا بإنشاء
مقاطع فيديو تعليمية لـ "تيك توك"
لكلبي  الاسم نيلسون يبلغ من
العمر عامين وهو كلب لابرادور أسود مهووس،
ما هي العلامات التي تظهر عندما
يكون حيوانك الأليف دافئًا للغاية،
وتأتي ضربة الشمس تدريجيًا ونحن
نعلم من الدراسات أن 98 كلبًا
تظهر عليهم علامات أخف من ضربة الشمس سوف
يتعافون تمامًا ولكن  في تلك الكلاب
التي تظهر تلك العلامات الأكثر خطورة،
يمكن أن تكون فرصها أكثر من 50 إلى 50. لذا فإن
الشيء الأساسي هو اصطيادها مبكرًا.
بعض السلالات الأكثر عرضة للخطر
يمكن أن تكون سلالاتك الشابة النشطة، إنها
سلالات الكلاب ذات الرأس العضدي
وكذلك كلاب البلدغ.  تعتمد كلاب البلدغ الفرنسية
على اللهاث لفقد الحرارة، وهذا
اللهاث ينطوي على تمرير الهواء داخل وخارج ممراتها الأنفية، وتتميز هذه الكلاب بوجه
مسطح ولديها
مساحة سطحية أقل في أنوفها،
وهذا هو كوبر، سلالته تسمى
كوكادور، هل يستطيع ذلك؟  المشي بأمان وممارسة التمارين الرياضية
لبضع ساعات، لا تشعر بالذنب لعدم
تمشية كلبك إذا كان الجو
حارًا للغاية هناك
طريقة واحدة لاختبار ما إذا كان السطح
سيكون ساخنًا جدًا بحيث لا يستطيع كلبك المشي
عليه أم لا، وهي استخدام قاعدة السبع ثواني.  لذلك
يمكنك وضع الجزء الخلفي من يدك على
السطح إذا لم تتمكن من الاحتفاظ بها بشكل
مريح لمدة سبع ثوانٍ، فسيكون الجو
حارًا جدًا بحيث لا يستطيع كلبك المشي هناك
إذا كان Cavapoo يبلغ من العمر ثلاثة أعوام، واسمها
ميني إذا كانوا يعتقدون أنها كذلك  لا تشرب،
نعطيها بعض الثلج المجمد، هذا
شيء أرى الكثير من المعلومات الخاطئة
عبر الإنترنت يقول الناس أنه يمكن أن يكون
ضارًا ولكن في الواقع، إذا كان بإمكانك إعطاء
حيواناتك الأليفة الثلج، فهناك خطر صغير جدًا
من أن يلحقوا الضرر بأسنانهم إذا
كانوا كذلك  إن مضغ قطع ضخمة من الطعام يكون
منطقيًا بعض الشيء لأنها
تنحدر من أنواع صحراوية أو على
شكل حرف V، لذا فهي تتكيف جيدًا مع
درجات الحرارة الأكثر دفئًا وتناول كميات أقل من الماء
إذا كانت في مناخ أكثر جفافًا
ولكن هذا لا يعني أنك
لا تحتاج إلى محاولة الحفاظ على
برودة حسابك إذا كان الجو حارًا جدًا،
فقد يكون الأمر صعبًا بعض الشيء ولكن من
الجيد محاولة تشجيعهم على
الشرب قدر الإمكان، يمكنك تجربة
تجميد مياه الينابيع من علب
التونة  ستكون بعض القطط سعيدة جدًا
بلعق الماء الذائب ببطء بسبب
ذلك،
فكلبي يحب حمامات الشمس وأعتقد أنه
يحب درجات الحرارة المتغيرة، لذا
غالبًا ما تحب الكلاب والقطط القيام بذلك يومًا ما،
ولنفس الأسباب التي
تجعلنا نحب أخذ حمام شمس  دفء ضوء
الشمس لطيف ويطلق
هرمونات جيدة مثل السيروتونين. إحدى المشاكل
التي نراها في القطط هي نوع من
سرطان الجلد ونرى هذا بشكل أكثر شيوعًا على
أطراف الأذن وحول الأنف
وهذا في القطط التي لديها ضوء.
الفراء الملون يجب أن تضع واقيًا من الشمس آمنًا للحيوانات الأليفة
في تلك المناطق، حيث
تكون الزواحف أقل عرضة
لضربة الشمس. تأكد من أنها حظيرة
لعدم تعرضها لأشعة الشمس المباشرة حتى لا
ترتفع درجة حرارة الطيور بشكل كبير إذا كان الجو
حارًا جدًا، قم برش بعض الماء حولها إذا كان الجو حارًا.
ساخن للغاية فكر في نقل
قفص أرنبك إلى الداخل حيث يكون الجو أكثر
برودة قليلاً، وكن حذرًا من أن
حوض السمك لا يسخن بشكل زائد، ومن الجيد أن يكون
لديك نظام جيد لتنقية المياه وتأكد من مراقبة
درجة حرارة الماء ولأن انخفاض
مستويات الأكسجين يمكن أن  جعل السمكة على ما يرام